hey Vsauce Michael here with a special
fact-filled video celebrating world of
warcraft in Cataclysm now even if you've
never played the game I've got seven
awesome things that are sure to tidily
titillate so much in fact I had to bring
in some friends to help
I've got Chad and Angie from the screen
team show hi Michael hi Vsauce I don't
know how you enter like that it's a head
brush all right first of all wow is
filled with a ton of great hidden images
like the word help written on top of a
mountain northeast of Thunder Bluff
there's a dinosaur crater in the
Outlands and there's these mountains
near Hammerfall that from the right
angles say LOL or the fact that if you
zoom out far enough in the valley of
Honor you can see that the whole thing
is actually Mickey Mouse all right but
let's be serious for a second guys the
most important hidden image and Wow is
this rock formation in the Barrens sorry
here's an image that actually came from
facebook.com slash Vsauce gaming it's a
it's not in sight Azeroth but it was
made out of stuff inside it it's a
mosaic of the wild logo fills out a
whole bunch of action icons from the
game okay I really love this one the
punch cards that you get in oh my god
are not just decorative the data that's
in them is binary code for all sorts of
funny sentences when you translate them
the white card says for all and Jana
sitting in a tree kis s ing it well it
reads that it doesn't really sing but
some of the cards are serious like the
code on the prismatic card it actually
translates to say message to cast pipe
your laundry's ready for pickup Wow has
always had its share of inside jokes
like Harrison Jones or the book in
epping hope that lists your own
character's name with the judgment needs
more cowbell died 1 I didn't know I want
to go there and see my character's name
another one they just added recently was
you remember the red shirt guy from
Blizzcon 2010 he stomped the developers
with a crazy question and blew
everybody's mind and they were like oh
we'll have to check on that while
they've recently put him in the game
he's standing an iron forge and his name
is the fact checker
exactly in one of the newest and most
fun references is plans versus zombies
and the hills bred foothills you can
accept a quest that recreates the game
and it gives you a chance to win a
grinning sunflower pets yes yeah that
incredible my guys know Chet stop
talking because I have to tell you
something very important I grew up in
Kansas so the sunflower pet like
completes my life nice its sticky it
sings in little girl's voice like and
it's creepy but it looks cute let's
switch gears to physics you probably
noticed that when it's daytime and
Kalimdor it's daytime in the Eastern
Kingdoms so are they on the same side of
the planet or is Azeroth lat well if you
if you think it's round like Earth then
check out this guy who did a geophysical
survey of the world of warcraft' by
literally measuring the world with human
paces and calculated its gravity by
timing his female torrents jumps he
found that the planet must be smaller
than the Death Star by quite a lot
unless of course there's an entire other
side we haven't seen future expansions
hint hint I hope so also on a related
note a guy in the comments of that video
actually pointed out that someone once
calculated that Ultima Online is about
the size of Disneyworld so if you like
those facts great but if you wish you
were dancing no problem you're in luck
click right here to view Chatham Angie's
new music video it's a spoof of Kanye
West's runaway
all about Cataclysm and world of
warcraft check it out click it you'll
love it I love it it looks great and as
always thanks for watching